pamela if you were going to arm a
screenwriter with one tool or weapon for
the purposes of screenwriting what would
it be for the purposes of screenwriting
what would be a good tool or weapon
persistence it's not easy
everybody thinks it is you go see a
movie you go watch written a better
movie than that you probably could but
it's an engineering skill screenwriting
whether it's for the big screen or for
TV or for web series it is engineering
you have to fit within parameters of
time often you have to fit within
parameters of production what you can
actually see easier now with you know
the computer-generated imagery that's
great
but you have to persist in learning the
craft and you have to persist in your
belief in yourself and your original
idea and your ability to keep improving
your skills and you have to persist in
the hardest part I think which is
marketing and getting your work out
there but persistence persistence
persistence never give up never
surrender someone said something great
that a lot of narcissists and this could
be a negative spin but I actually found
it enlightening make it because they
have such belief in themselves that all
the knows don't really face them as much
very true certainly for pitching I think
the most important tool is enthusiasm
but for the actual writing the
screenplay its persistence because you
need to the conventional wisdom is that
ask somebody who has had a successful
sale what version of the script sold and
how many others they've written it's
usually it's the tenth draft and it's
the fifth screenplay that they've
written oh wow yeah so you just have to
keep at it and keep at it and keep at it
and keep at it again but for pitching
enthusiasm the
it's contagious and what the people
receiving pitches want to know is it's
my audience is going to be enthused
about this and if you're enthused about
it
then they catch that and you you spark
off that imagination oh I think I can
start seeing how this could work a lot
of writers are more introverted and shy
and maybe Hedy how do they drum up that
enthusiasm when they walk in that room
and they're probably terrified it is
difficult and we do pitching for people
who often can't come here because
they're out of the country or their job
won't let them or whatever so I know
that it's easier to pitch other people's
things than it is to pitch your own I
know that because I do both all writers
are introverts but I think if you can
step outside yourself and think of
yourself as an audience member and
relate the story that you would like to
see on screen
it was once pitching for a client and
it's a story I love and it's just scary
it's a horror thriller and went in sat
down and I said well my friend can't be
here but I'm pitching his story for him
and it's a horror thriller and it's a
female lead and this and that he's gone
again I said here's how scary this book
is I had to put it in the freezer at
night because it was so scary I couldn't
keep it out in my bedroom or in the
living room I stuck it in the freezer
it's that scary and I even get chills
talking about it right
well that level of enthusiasm think that
you're your friend pitching for you or
think that you are an audience member
who just saw the movie what are you
going to text and tweet and blog about
your film
once you see it as somebody else so just
pretend you're somebody else and put on
put on your cloaking device
you